- But I also heard that COVID
has hit close to home with you,
so you have loved ones
working in the hospitals
right now, right?
- Yeah, well it hasn't
hit, so far, thank God.
Like touch wood, I'm like,
my sister is a midwife
with the National Health Service here,
and my partner's sister and stepmother
are both NHS nurses as well.
So between the three of us we've got three
members of family that
are, you know, well,
front line in the community or a hospital.
So I don't know how often you guys do it,
but we go outside and, you know,
bang for, clap for carers,
bang our pots and pans,
and clap for our National
Health Service staff
and our carers every Thursday evening,
and so we're out there giving it loads,
and, you know, we just
worry about them, because,
but I'm so proud.
I'm so ridiculously proud,
Kelly, of my sister.
And she was an elderly
carer in the community
before she was a midwife.
She's just one of those people
that's just, like, she's just--
- [Kelly] A nurturer.
- Yeah, she's a nurturer.
And she's just so good, and she has,
she just has that capacity.
Enormous mental, as well
as physical capacity,
and I know it's the same with you guys,
your side of the pond as us.
It's like, to our medical staff,
we are just so indebted.
- Yeah, 'cause you didn't, it's weird,
but we didn't even think
about it before, you know,
we always, I take my kids,
you know, to the doctor,
I do all this stuff, you know,
you always go to the doctor,
you don't think about it,
but God, this is really opened your eyes
to how much of a servants
heart they all have.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause a lot of these
nurses have kids and families
and, you know, they
don't wanna bring it home
and infect their families.
So, it's just a different
level of sacrifice
that none of us will ever know.
- [Natalie] Yeah, it's so true.
David, my partner, his sister
has got two kids under five.
And she's, you know,
front line as a nurse.
And I'm just like, you know,
it's like, what do I do?
I make stories for a living.
It's like, it really does help you,
I mean I know people need
escapism, and it's cool.
- Beautiful distraction,
like that's a, don't--